one of the problems we have in
discussing consciousness scientifically
is that consciousness is irreducibly
subjective this is a point that many
philosophers have made Thomas Nagel John
Searle David Chalmers and I've well I
don't agree with everything they've said
about consciousness I agree with them on
this point that consciousness is what
it's like to be you if there's if
there's an experiential internal
qualitative dimension to any physical
system then that is consciousness and we
can't reduce the experiential side to
talk of information processing and
neurotransmitters and and states of the
brain in our case because and then
people want to do this someone like
Francis Crick said famously you're
nothing but a pack of neurons and that
that misses the fact that that half of
the reality we are talking about is the
qualitative experiential side so when
you're trying to study human
consciousness for instance by looking at
states of the brain all you can do is
correlate experiential changes with
changes in brain States but no matter
how tight these correlations become that
never gives you license to throw out the
first-person experiential side they'd be
analogous to saying that if you just
flipped a coin long enough you would
realize it had only one side and now
it's true you can be committed to
talking about just one side you can say
that that heads being up it's just the
case of tails being down but that
doesn't actually reduce one side of
reality to the other and to get to give
you a more precise example we have very
strong third person quote objective
measures of things like anxiety and fear
at this moment you bring someone to the
lab they say they're feeling fear you
can scan their brains with fMRI and see
that there are big d'leh response is
heightened you can you can measure the
sweat on their palms and see that see
that there's a increased galvanic skin
response you can you can check their
blood cortisol and see that it's spiking
so these these now are considered
objective third-person measures of fear
but if half the people came into the lab
tomorrow and said they were feeling fear
and showed none of these signs and they
said they were that completely calm when
their cortisol spiked and when their
their palm started to sweat these
objective measures would no longer be
reliable measures of fear so so the cash
value of a change in physiology is still
a change in the first person conscious
side of things and and we're we're
inevitably going to rely on people's
subjective reports to to understand
whether our correlations are accurate so
the hope that we are going to talk about
consciousness shorn of any kind of
qualitative internal experiential
language I think is a false one so we
have to understand both sides of it's
subjective classically subjective and
objective I'm not arguing that
consciousness is a reality beyond
science or beyond the brain or that it's
it floats free of the brain of death I'm
not I'm not making any spooky claims
about its its metaphysics what I am
saying however is that the self is an
illusion the sense of being an ego and I
think er of thoughts in addition to the
thoughts a an experience or in addition
to the experience that the sense that we
all have of riding around inside our
heads as a kind of a passenger in the
vehicle of the body that's that's where
most people start when they when they
think about any of these questions most
people don't feel identical to their
bodies they feel like they have bodies
they feel like they're inside the body
and most people feel like they're inside
their heads
now that sense of being a subject a
locus of consciousness inside the head
is an illusion that it makes no narrow
anatomical sense there's no place in the
brain for your ego to be hiding we know
that that everything you experience your
your conscious emotions and thoughts and
and moods and the the impulses that
initiate behavior all of these things
are delivered by by myriad different
processes in the brain that are spread
out over the whole of the brain that
they can be independently erupted
there's the we have a changing system we
are a process and there's not one
unitary self that's carried through from
one moment to the next
unchanging and yet we feel that we have
this this self that's just the center of
experience now it's possible I claim and
people have claimed for thousands of
years to lose this feel
to actually have the center drop out of
experience so that you just rather than
feeling like you are on this side of
things looking in your so you're almost
looking over your own shoulder how
appropriating experience in each moment
you can just be identical to this sphere
of experience that is all of the color
and life and feeling and energy of
consciousness but there's no sense of
center there so so this is classically
described as self transcendence or ego
transcendence in in spiritual mystical
new-age religious literature it is in
large measure the baby in the bathwater
that religious people are afraid to
throw out it's it's if you want to take
seriously the project of being like
Jesus or Buddha or some whatever your
favorite contemplative is self
transcendence really is at the core of
the phenomenology that is described
there and what I'm saying is that we
that it's it's a real experience it's
clearly an experience that people can
have and while it tells you nothing
about the cosmos it tells you nothing
about what happened before the Big Bang
it tells you nothing about the divine
origin of certain books it doesn't make
religious dogmas any more plausible it
does tell you something about the nature
of human consciousness it tells you
something about it tells us something
about the possibilities of experience
but then again any experience does you
know you can you can just people have
extraordinary experiences and the
problem with religion is that they
extrapolate people extrapolate from
those experiences and make grandiose
claims about the nature of the universe
but these experiences do entitle you to
talk about the the the nature of human
consciousness and it just so happens
that this experience of self
transcendence does link up with what we
know about the mind through neuroscience
to form an actual awza between science
and and classic mysticism classic
spirituality because if you lose your
sense of a unitary self if you lose your
sense that there's a permanent
unchanging center to consciousness your
experience of the world actually becomes
more faithful to the facts it's it's not
a distortion of
the way we think things are at the level
of the brain is actually it brings your
experience into closer register with how
we think things are